first up he is the chairman of the
American Conservative Union my old job
and host host of Sirius XM CPAC 365
match lap is very brave to come there ok
Matt so you are the man who how long
have you been running CPAC five years or
so five years when did it start CPAC God
after Barry Goldwater guy Oh way back
way back
okay so original group right so this
year now I don't know if you see a lot
of liberal media I do I actually appear
on a lot of liberal media you're here
exactly that's right and this is
something that's actually pretty
important it is and I've been trying to
get the Democrats to go on Fox News they
should that's they should of course you
check the demos the Fox there's a lot of
independents and Democrats watching it
you've got to get inside the bubble
that's right right I mean you may not
convert a lot of people here but maybe
one well it was a pretty close election
you know an election can be determined
based on these kind of strategies and
you should you should be smart enough to
go everywhere you need to go but Michael
Cohen at the end of his testimony gave a
kind of a warning he did and he said you
know I worked for Trump for ten years
and I believed him and I lied for him
and I followed him and those of who are
doing that now you were going to suffer
the same fate as me did you see any sort
of ghost of Christmas future when he
said oh you you don't see any parallels
I I don't associate myself with mr.
Cohen I'm no I know but what he said
that he'd lied for Trump that he's
supported Trump I mean you support Trump
fully you are we've talked before we
have you're not unaware of his myriad
flaws I'm not
well Cohen slaw okay no but no I'm just
saying like this week we saw manna fort
go to jail sentence to jail right yep a
metaphor here's a guy who was deeply
into debt to this Russian oligarch Terah
posa
right then he becomes campaign manager
for Trump for free just walks in out of
the door says you know Putin really he's
kind of an asset of Putin and now he's
Trump's campaign manager right you don't
think this is going to haunt you in the
future look we all have to put on our
big-boy pants and make decisions and I
made a decision back in 2016 that I
thought Donald Trump would be a much
better president than Hillary Clinton
but now we just can disagree with ya but
now but now we've seen him as president
and he nothing has changed your mind
actually what he told me he was gonna do
as president he has simply done all the
major things he ran on people don't have
to agree wall people don't have to agree
you don't have to agree with what he
said he was gonna do right but what did
he say he was gonna do held a wall in
Mexico would pay for it he did say he
was gonna build a wall
he's not building a wall yes not true
that's not true well there's no money to
build a wall not true it's the second
year in a row that we've gotten money so
you want to call it a fence a wall a
barrier it's happening whatever it is it
is it's it's it's not happening you're
seeing things now because you're cult
leader says you should why are you I go
down to the Rio Grande Valley together
we'll go see what's but he said it would
cost twenty five billion dollars he
could not get me to because he doesn't
have the money because we still sort of
live in a democracy okay so yeah well I
don't know how much longer he just had a
meeting with Kim he did right and at the
end of it he was talking about the young
American who was killed over there
tortured to death yeah and he said when
asked about he said Kim told me he
didn't do it I take him at his word what
do you think of that you saw something
like that that happened after you
supported Trump in 2016 I did that that
doesn't change you knew it from him
killed that young man so I think as the
dictator I think is a horrible person
and I think the bad thing is where does
that leave you with these got nuclear
weapons but we're trying to make sure
that we don't have where does it leave
you with Trump defending Kim and
believing him
well did you probably listen to the two
hours and 20 minutes of the seatbacks no
but he actually brought this up and said
that he does believe that the regime is
responsible for all these that's not
what he said is it when he said in
Vietnam I could read you the quote it
was a very simple quote it was a as Kim
told me he didn't I would I take him at
his word I read the quote I'm giving you
my opinion my opinion is that these are
senior they kill people okay but he said
he believed Kim I understand that and
what I also understand is he's in
nuclear diplomacy to try to make sure
that we don't have like a nuclear weapon
all right well here in Hawaii okay
that's a different answer if you're
saying it's okay to kill one guy just
okay no it's not okay he doesn't he
didn't say he was glad that these people
are being he said it doesn't terrify you
that he believes other day he said the
same thing about Putin they were
explaining to him that Kim had nuclear
weapons I'm talking about the CIA
explaining to him they were explaining
to him that Kim could reach us and he
said I don't think so I believe Putin he
told
Coria doesn't have well what about
giving the malign around 150 billion
dollars their profits and this is a
great idea let's answer this question
first and we didn't give them the money
it was unfrozen you know that but they
got the cash they got the cash we used
we froze yes there or something right we
he didn't get anything he they got the
cash for it
dismantling their nuclear program and
did that he put up with the mullahs so
that he could get what he thought was a
higher purpose which was to rid Iran of
having nuclear capabilities that's why
that's what he did let me ask you this
any went into the pockets of terrorists
his children this week we found out he
demanded that they get security
clearance again over the objections of
the CIA and the FBI do you think this is
what the founders had in mind that
someone who loses the election by three
million votes then gets to put his kids
in government you're a big founder guy
or conservatives
is that what they had it Mike yeah they
liked the Electoral College that's why
they created it no problem with that and
they don't have any there was never any
issue with Rozlyn what about her kids
what about when Roslyn cars look good
she'd go to any meeting Jimmy Carter
said she can walk into anything she
wasn't elected to do anything Dick
Cheney's kids worked for him and in
position but it wasn't in charge of the
Middle East she was in charge of
anything she wanted to be I don't
remember that you know I don't remember
Rosalyn Carter I don't remember that
well fact is that kid of any luck with
that here's here's what presidents do
presidents have advised they have the
advisors they want to have they reach
out and talk to anybody they want to
talk to you whether you go through a
background process or not most
presidents have decided to confide in
their spouses and their children to
great lengths they different these to
her is they decide to go you can do it
just don't tell me it's not
unprecedented
it's completely unprecedented to put
your son-in-law in charge of the Middle
East I agree with that
thank you so okay so I have been saying
many times in this very chair two guests
who were kind of laughing at me that
Donald Trump even if he loses the
election in 2020 is not gonna go away
and I found some vindication when
Michael Cohen concluded his testimony
when they asked him why are you here
right and Michael Cohen said I'm here
because having worked with mr. Trump for
so long I don't think he will leave he
knows Crump pretty well what do you
think of that I think it's absurd you
think Trump will leave I have these
flashbacks to 2016 when I was told that
election night Donald Trump wouldn't
accept the results of the election it's
immaterial because he wasn't he said
before the election he might not accept
the results if he lose but Hillary
Clinton was the one that didn't accept
the results that night she waited till
the next day right so next day I think
I'll time talking about him just staying
there who you're talking about it
doesn't mean okay so let me ask you this
but is it okay if I have the opinion
that I think that if you lose this he
will pack up yes he might even want to
leave because it's it hasn't probably
been that no he's not gonna want to
leave because he knows he'd go to jail
he
is that it if he if he doesn't and he's
made murmurs to this gentle I mean he
said many times bitterly do murmurs he
just says it straight okay he's more
that kind of guy
if he doesn't leave if it is a free and
fair election and by the way even if
it's suspect it's up to the courts to
decide would you break with him then if
he did not leave you would you would
break with Donald Trump regular anyone
okay all right it's all right well look
this is a guy who does things that are
out of the norm that the degree with the
declaring of a national emergency taking
that which many Republicans are against
it's true right okay so that's take
there's gonna be a big vote in the
Senate it's an open question as to
whether or not they're gonna have the
votes
when you when you take upon yourself a
power like that when you say I want this
power actually Congress passed a law
that was upheld by the Supreme Court
that gives him that power not to do what
he did it know what not not about things
like this where the Congress has voted
on something this is about the power of
the purse he's taking their
constitutional right
learning's all the money bill I mean we
can criticize both parties for this all
that money has been appropriated
Congress sends all of this extra money
into these accounts and maybe Congress
ought to be a lot more penurious about
what they put over in the executive
branch and the fact is we have over 30
of these emergencies that have been
declared for all kinds of reasons like
this and you know what this one is the
president's responsibility clearly in
law okay so let me ask you about Fox
News that was another big story this
week there was a large article in The
Enquirer of Enquirer
[Laughter]
New York will be in the enquires that's
my destiny I'm very worried no that's
right
je Maya does not work for The Enquirer
but she's saying that basically Fox News
is running our government which I think
we know because Trump watches Fox and
Friends in the morning and then he
tweets very often as he's watching it
sometimes he doesn't even refer to what
he is tweeting you just have to know
that's what he's watching sometime he's
just gonna tweet oh yeah but what do you
want this is completely but this is
unprecedented - I mean the fact that
Sean Hannity does his show every night
praising Trump and then after the show
Sean Hannity and Trump talk now if Obama
was talking to Rachel Maddow every night
what do you think well I mean I remember
what we just said I remember the Obama
presidency when Fox News actually wasn't
treated like a news outlet I think that
was a mistake
and I think that what's going on this is
different this is the the president
United States talking every day to the
people on the station that he like I'm
gonna give you a dirty little theater if
Obama talked to Rachel Maddow every day
what would you myself no did he I don't
know if he didn't I don't know I promise
you he'll accept I'm asking me what see
I have this book it's called if Obama
did it
present you with a copy weapon I just
want to read a few things if his
campaign manager went to jail if his
lawyer went to jail if his national
security adviser went to jail if his
albino assassin Roger stone went to jail
have you had an affair with a porn star
paid hush money to a porn star if he
used an unsecure phone if he gloated
when with the Russians in his office
after firing the head of the FBI stop me
if you find any of these if he had
unchaperoned talks with Putin can you
imagine if Obama did that if he said I
believe Putin if he gave his children
jobs in the administration what about
this one he scammed FEMA we found out he
got 17 million dollars out of FEMA for
damage that wasn't done during a
hurricane tomorrow law go that alone
they would have impeached Obama oh you
couldn't keep going through all of that
night right I
you got you not allowed me I am let me
give you the let me give you what's
going around what my opinion politics
okay
is that everyone can continue to say
that eases you said a scam artist that
he's a liar all these questions he told
people across this country that he was
gonna do five or six big things right
Tomatoes whatever else he does that but
let me just try to answer the question
for a politician who is actually keeping
the big promises he has made which you
really can't deny he said he was gonna
move that embassy he moved that
embassies so he was gonna get out of
Iran deal he got out of the Iran deal he
said he was going to get out of the pair
of steel he got out of the Paris deal he
said he was gonna kiss act he's undone a
lot huh you're right he said and I
understand a lot of you didn't like the
fact of what he was saying on the
campaign trail but you can't deny that
on these big questions he did it now a
lot of people on the other side of the
equation for me don't like that he did
that and when people in the news media
have this constant refrain that he has
been so dishonest as president they have
to understand for the people who
supported him he is simply doing he they
view him as doing what he said he would
do
thank you Matt he's coming on there
[Applause]
you